but personally like I can't really speak
on information like like I we started to
believe all women like I don't know you
like that's fair
and at least seen men be more violent
towards women and I haven't ever seen a
woman be violent towards her partner
I've seen girls hit guys and nobody does
anything
I haven't seen that and I what kind of
hit like a little knock on the shoulder
or like any hit is unacceptable and if
you if you hit a man you should expect
to get hit back
uh why would you hit someone and not
expect to get hit back
men don't have that like why are women
special
like why do we get a special privilege
that men don't get if if he hits him
he's getting hit back